[Music]
5 25 and you're back to work back to
school Monday well don't stop me even if
you've heard this one before because yep
they are doing it again
the Nevada Department of Transportation
going to be shutting down Tropicana at
midnight tonight between the strip and
Dean Martin Drive four another round of
tweaks to the diverging diamond indot
constantly reviewing traffic cameras for
any confusion about the right way to get
across Tropicana and how to turn left
from the Northbound I-15 exit member
when indot spokesman Justin Hopkins
talked about that ramp so it's
counterintuitive move because you are
normally when you take
traffic but in this we
Miss we went left and stay in the left
lane
and that closure scheduled to run
midnight tonight until five tomorrow
morning but even if you miss the closure
itself you gotta keep your eyes peeled
in that diverging diamond and you want
to stay tuned for Wednesday's report on
even more I-15 drop news that's the
start of the construction on a half
freeway interchange at Harmon buckle up
drive carefully please put on that phone
you can join the driving crazy
conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com